la segunda edición de esta jornada de
protestas ha dejado de momento más de
4.000 detenidos en toda rusia lo cual
supone romper el récord de detenciones
de el pasado fin de semana a estas horas
la policía rusa aquí en moscú sigue
cerrando calle a calle el acceso a los
manifestantes y los está expulsando poco
a poco del centro de la ciudad una
ciudad que ha amanecido hoy con siete
estaciones de metro en el centro
cerradas para poner coto a estas
movilizaciones que no tienen el permiso
de las autoridades a estas horas el
equipo de naval ha dado por finalizada
las protestas pero según las
informaciones que nos están llegando las
detenciones se siguen produciendo de
hecho algunos grupos de manifestantes se
están marchando hacia la prisión
moscovita de matrioska piscina donde
está encerrado al ex en avant y su
intención es protestar allí pidiendo su
liberación